heartbreaking get-together as the
community of Cleveland remembered the
five people gunned down with an AR-15
style rifle hundreds of deputies and
detectives combed the region north of
Houston for the men police say went on a
deadly Rampage inside this home we do
not know where he is we don't have any
tips right now the attack happened
Friday night the sheriff says after
outside could fall asleep he says it's
his property he'll do whatever he
pleases on his property
the man went back in the house next
thing they know he's walking up the
driveway with the rifle in hand deputies
say the suspect had been drinking before
he entered the neighbor's home and
started firing according to the Honduran
foreign Ministry those killed are Diana
Velasquez Abdullah Molina Jonathan
casares
Sonia Guzman and nine-year-old Daniel
Enrique lasso